you guys ready 3 2 1
alright I'm gonna turn this off now so I
can pleasure myself at Memphis okay so
what are we doing today I don't know how
you how it's best to describe it wait
like where do we
when do we touch ourselves first of all
it's all it's today we're gonna get our
sperm counts tested this topic is very
important to me because I want to have
children I'm actually really interested
to find out if my sperm are normal it's
not something you think about you're
just like yeah my dick work then we
talked about fertility we talked about
women having to get tested a lot but not
as much about men do you think that's
true it's absolutely true and it's
absolutely not fair we don't really know
how big of a problem this is because a
lot of couples will either give up and
not come in and a lot of guys won't
think there's anything wrong with it
every guy is terrified of having a baby
but I feel like secretly we're more
terrified of not being able to have a
baby
I'm nervous don't be nervous it's really
easy you've done this at home a thousand
times more than that basically you're
going to collect sperm into a cup we
were planning on making it a race if
we're gonna try and be the quickest now
to think about my wife so I'm in the
masturbatorium about to get fun credit
and it couldn't be weirder what do i
yeah you just came out one time with it
5:07 your crash that jerk
drop that you're out the DVD player
won't work guys we did it
654 that's respectable how long does it
normally take maybe 10 minutes is
average 1225 I took time to wash my
hands after I think I'm just gonna use
my imagine oh oh
that's almost he's done 16 minutes I'm
just worried I'm done that was a
disaster
oh sorry good news I did it bad news is
that I missed in the cut not much
where'd the rest of go rather not say
Eugene sperm and seaming together are
analyzed in something called a semen
analysis well actually take the sample
we'll put it in the Machine and it
calibrates reads the semen gives us a
report it's almost fully loaded which is
a choice term a little nervous because
actually seeing it in numbers on paper
is gonna be really eye-opening I'm not
feeling very optimistic right now I just
hope that I'm okay I just hope that I'm
normal moment of truth
the sperm like to be about two degrees
colder than the rest of the body the
heat from a laptop is enough to cook
those sperm anything that can get in the
way of sperm cooling is a bad thing I've
been wearing boxers always preparation
boxers a great exercise exercise is
wonderful I'm over three on that and
stress is another big we didn't into you
know there's a lot of toxins that are
bad for sperm alcohol it's okay
anything in moderation is probably okay
so the biggest ways to make your sperm
counts go to zero it is taking a
supplemental testosterone things that
are pretty neutral caffeine it makes a
mood right smoking smoking it's a sign
of stress on the sperm but it's not a
deal-breaker
we don't really have a lot of data on
pot perfect I think that your sperm are
really a good bellwether for how the
rest of your body is if you have
abnormalities with your sperm then
there's something else going wrong in
your life let's talk about the way one
measures sperm the quantitative part is
how much volume or how much liquid comes
out when a man ejaculates it's 0.4 0.4
way no that's not much it's not the
highest volume of the jacket it comes in
a second the other quantitative thing is
how many sperm come out in that
ejaculation this is how many million per
milliliter med and Eugene both are in
the 70 million 3.4 was your volume 1070
3.1 gives you a total sperm count of two
hundred forty eight point six million
Eugene 237 point six million per
ejaculate we're still competing on a
molecular level
Zach was at thirty-seven point nine
million keith is extremely high
concentration at 128 million is really
only at about sixty million mistakes
were made mistakes were definitely made
but it takes one right I wonder what my
boys look like we just take out a
dropper and put it in a special slide
and we look at it under a microscope
that keeps sperm are really good at
wiggling like oh zach is gonna have the
hairiest sperm Eugene's has it kind of
sperm too like trips other sperm on the
way the egg my only hope is that Ned has
the strongest fastest sperm
what what yeah the qualitative aspects
are the shape of the sperm which is what
we call morphology there's your sperm
there they are look at them oh look at
those little idiots that one has two
tails right there Wow only 4% of them
have to be considered morphologically
normal which means you've got 96% of
your sperm or Nikolai's Wow focus in
that they are doing a dance the other
qualitative thing is how fast they're
moving to get up to an egg that sperm is
running the microscopic equivalent
running from Los Angeles to San
Francisco a little guys they look happy
and healthy and fun can we all have kids
you guys are all armed and dangerous
yeah whatever helps D Sigma ties any
sort of health related thing for a man
it's good if you can't produce then what
kind of man are you that is a huge cross
to bear no you know less of a man what
you do in real life is what makes you a
man so don't be afraid to check it out
and it's better than no sooner than
later because some of these things are
reversible there's a lot of things that
we don't even know that we do daily that
affects our genitals and our future
babies isn't if they're gonna have
difficulty we're gonna find some way to
get that culprit pregnant there are so
many ways to start a family even if
there is a problem all that said my
sperm are ready to have babies
oh man I would name that one Keith I
would name this one these two key
congratulate check his pulse
that was actually great I had a great
time it was a nightmare it was the worst
masturbation of all time